Caption: but in the meantime I will give a bit of
Caption: an intro so Josh is here with us today
Caption: he's a distinguished technologist at
Caption: cantino he's also a published author
Caption: which I think is bloody Wicked he's
Caption: generally
Caption: he is generally referred to at cantino
Caption: as the break glass in case of emergency
Caption: made human
Caption: he works with businesses all over
Caption: Australia helping them to digitally
Caption: transform he will also be taking some
Caption: questions and from what I hear that are
Caption: signing of the book could be a
Caption: possibility guys so Josh are we good
Caption: hopefully let's give it a red hot go if
Caption: you can use that one so we can all hear
Caption: you I mean people can probably hear me
Caption: oh God people can probably hear me
Caption: anyway so I'm generally loud all right
Caption: serverless testing uh local considered
Caption: harmful so people may have heard me
Caption: speak before in which case you might
Caption: have presumed this warning was coming
Caption: it's going to be a lot of strong
Caption: opinions they're hopefully loosely held
Caption: your mileage may vary I'm not saying I
Caption: have all the answers just most of them
Caption: so you know we'll have to see how that
Caption: goes right
Caption: all right the hero slash villain uh for
Caption: our story today it's a friend of mine
Caption: called Richards who I worked with in the
Caption: UK
Caption: um he's drunk the cloud native Kool-Aid
Caption: as you can see
Caption: um that is a suit he actually owns
Caption: um so when I talk about Cloud native
Caption: I'm not meaning this Unholy Cambrian
Caption: explosion of things that the cncf has
Caption: really it's building for the cloud not
Caption: just on the cloud right that can mean
Caption: kubernetes but I argue in most cases it
Caption: probably not
Caption: but okay so
Caption: back to Richard and we're gonna we're
Caption: gonna start and I always try and start
Caption: this way so when people get bored of me
Caption: speaking hopefully they've got the
Caption: takeaways to start so we're going to
Caption: start with the three key takeaways
Caption: the first is that the testing pyramid
Caption: that we've all held dear to our hearts
Caption: for many many years is a service
Caption: anti-pattern in reality
Caption: um hopefully some of these are
Caption: contentious I'm hoping to you know piss
Caption: people off as we go
Caption: um again it makes it more fun
Caption: um second emulating the cloud is a
Caption: recipe for disappointment I will be
Caption: ragging on local stack for about half
Caption: this talk maybe not half but you know
Caption: you've got to go with me on this and
Caption: hopefully I can convince you to throw it
Caption: in the bin tomorrow and the last is
Caption: testing doesn't stop when code hits
Caption: production
Caption: um again hopefully people agree with me
Caption: on this or they don't either way
Caption: hopefully you agree with me by the end
Caption: so there's already an intro on me so
Caption: I'll go very very quick
Caption: um so yeah we're seeing this technology
Caption: container which is a ridiculous title
Caption: um I work with Enterprises I've done
Caption: world first service architecture on AWS
Caption: um I've done mainframes I've done
Caption: machine learning
Caption: um I am a speaker and I do have a few
Caption: copies to give away I can sign them if
Caption: you want but I feel really weird doing
Caption: it
Caption: um I'm davido's Ambassador hashing
Caption: Ambassador you know all the kind of
Caption: stuff I'm a professional lab mouth
Caption: um so I'm going to talk about functional
Caption: testing today when I say testing that's
Caption: what most people think and there are so
Caption: many other things you can and should be
Caption: testing but I have 45 minutes so I'm
Caption: going to focus or try anyway I generally
Caption: add lead a lot so we'll see how this
Caption: goes uh why do we test and I just
Caption: realized I have that slide twice why do
Caption: we test
Caption: is it to prevent bugs
Caption: yes and no
Caption: um kind of
Caption: I'm gonna apologies for this I'm going
Caption: to go a little bit of complexity Theory
Caption: um
Caption: so when we build systems they are
Caption: complex adaptive systems it's a very uh
Caption: very long way of saying when we make
Caption: changes we don't really know what's
Caption: going to happen we have ideas we have
Caption: theories but we can't know what's going
Caption: to happen
Caption: and if you don't believe me or this is
Caption: kind of new I think we've all been
Caption: through this you know you're working on
Caption: something you know you get to daily
Caption: stand-up the next day and yeah no I
Caption: found something new it's kind of the
Caption: it's the problem and the fun of software
Caption: development it's emergent you don't know
Caption: what you're doing until you do it which
Caption: is why estimating another one of my uh
Caption: pain points is pointless and that's
Caption: probably also going to piss some people
Caption: off which is fantastic
Caption: going from complexity Theory
Caption: um
Caption: so behaviors of systems of complex
Caption: adapter systems an emergent property you
Caption: can try and control them but effectively
Caption: they happen not 100 by chance but just
Caption: because you build something doesn't mean
Caption: you know what it's going to do
Caption: this also means that unintended
Caption: behaviors are emergent property because
Caption: you don't know what's going to happen
Caption: which that means that bugs an emergent
Caption: property because bugs is effectively
Caption: just a synonym for unintended behaviors
Caption: the bugs are inevitable
Caption: um you're really not going to get around
Caption: them so if testing isn't about the you
Caption: know preventing bugs in their entirety
Caption: what what are you actually trying to
Caption: achieve
Caption: really for me it's this the the value of
Caption: the release you're trying to do the
Caption: value of the change you're trying to do
Caption: is greater than the risk of doing the
Caption: change
Caption: that's all you're trying to really do
Caption: you're trying to go actually putting
Caption: this change of production is more
Caption: valuable than the potential risk impact
Caption: you can't be sure about this it's all
Caption: about confidence you can have to be 100
Caption: confidence even with an ego as big as
Caption: mine I can never be 100 confident that
Caption: I've got it right
Caption: um but really what fundamentally what
Caption: we're trying to do is how cheaply can
Caption: you be confident or sufficiently
Caption: confident that the value of the release
Caption: is more than the risk and obviously risk
Caption: can take many different factors in terms
Caption: of you break production or unintended or
Caption: the you know there's all the damage that
Caption: comes from that in terms of Financial
Caption: and reputational and maybe you get
Caption: smarts across the head because you've
Caption: released so many bugs into production
Caption: there's lots of different kinds of risk
Caption: in there
Caption: again just stepping back to complexity
Caption: Theory one last time I promise I'll move
Caption: on
Caption: um when you look at complex area and
Caption: then you get test run are these enabling
Caption: constraints they allow us to preserve
Caption: certain behaviors of the system but
Caption: they're not guaranteed to exercise the
Caption: entirety of the system so you're not
Caption: going to cover everything but you're
Caption: going to cover a lot
Caption: Google very eloquently put it uh like
Caption: this
Caption: um the Beyonce rule if you liked it you
Caption: should have put a CI test on it Google
Caption: have taken this idea to the extreme with
Caption: the idea that anyone in the business can
Caption: make pretty much any change to any
Caption: system that they want
Caption: so upgrading a package take the log4j
Caption: thing that happened right Google can
Caption: update that in their one giant monorepo
Caption: they are insane
Caption: um but that can be done by security and
Caption: if your system breaks it is your fault
Caption: not theirs
Caption: so it's changing with accountability
Caption: lies from the person that made to change
Caption: the person that owns the system but
Caption: fundamentally Google has probably second
Caption: to non-testing culture and it enables a
Caption: lot of the stuff that they do
Caption: again
Caption: when we build a system we have a mental
Caption: model of how we think the system works
Caption: and we have a software model which is
Caption: how the system actually works and
Caption: testing is an opportunity to refine our
Caption: mental to try and bring it closer to the
Caption: software model and the closer you are
Caption: the better the quicker you can develop
Caption: the less bugs you're going to introduce
Caption: this is kind of the basis around you
Caption: know when you're on board onto a new
Caption: team you have to understand what's going
Caption: on right
Caption: so as you know you have to build these
Caption: mental models over time which is why you
Caption: get the guys who've worked on the system
Caption: for 20 years seem to know everything
Caption: backwards and forwards and the guy's
Caption: been there two months it's like what the
Caption: hell is going on
Caption: really common refrain that I see when
Caption: people start on the serverless bit is
Caption: they find that testing just feels really
Caption: hard
Caption: it feels really hard for them to do
Caption: they're like man it doesn't work the way
Caption: it used to
Caption: um you know I'm starting to do a whole
Caption: bunch of different things it's not
Caption: really working like all of a sudden I
Caption: need Docker compose to run like 10
Caption: containers on my laptop and it's set on
Caption: fire that kind of stuff that you see
Caption: happening around the track right
Caption: the fundamental problems that although
Caption: serverless you know Lambda functions and
Caption: Cloud run and visual functions all that
Caption: wonderful stuff although there is
Caption: technology Service as a whole is
Caption: actually a mindset it's not just about
Caption: moving the technology it's a new
Caption: paradigm that comes with new ways of
Caption: working if you try and apply all the
Caption: ways you used to do things in like a
Caption: monolithic on-premise environment to a
Caption: serverless environment you can have a
Caption: bad time which is what a lot of people
Caption: do
Caption: if you try and do Cloud native
Caption: development with a pre-cloud testing
Caption: approach local Dev sub is hellish you
Caption: know the working with some Enterprise
Caption: like oh someone's onboarding cool all
Caption: right well it might have the laptops out
Caption: ready to go in two weeks it's like
Caption: that's a lot of time I've worked on
Caption: teams where we had people joining
Caption: pushing to production within an hour of
Caption: joining if you get this stuff right you
Caption: can move so fast testing across multiple
Caption: Services is brittle
Caption: um this is something people find when
Caption: they go to microservices like oh my God
Caption: what is this how do I get the same level
Caption: of confidence and really comes down to
Caption: the tests they write are either really
Caption: hard they're hard to be impactful
Caption: because either they're very brittle and
Caption: really hard to work with or they're kind
Caption: of tortological tests are really not
Caption: testing anything at all and they kind of
Caption: end up in this really weird space where
Caption: they're like I don't have any confidence
Caption: that my system even works when I make a
Caption: change
Caption: and coming back to this serverless as a
Caption: mindset piece there's kind of Three core
Caption: drivers that led to it and they all have
Caption: impacts on the way you test
Caption: um
Caption: so these are kind of wider macroeconomic
Caption: things but really this is what the cloud
Caption: to a large degree has brought to itm
Caption: businesses so it historically and
Caption: unfortunately still in some places seen
Caption: as a cost center
Caption: um you don't want it to be you want to
Caption: see The Innovation Center
Caption: um with that comes a very different
Caption: level of expectation you are expected to
Caption: produce value not maintain costs ideally
Caption: um generally we're moving to modernist
Caption: and microservices if you're going down a
Caption: serverless path you're going to end up
Caption: doing microservices that kind of is no
Caption: way about it and you know if you're
Caption: deploying one Lambda there's God that
Caption: does everything
Caption: um think again
Caption: um
Caption: and one of the more interesting bits
Caption: especially compared to a on-premise
Caption: world that used to be long lead times I
Caption: need a new service setting up okay the
Caption: best case is maybe it goes to the server
Caption: team that goes and sets something up the
Caption: worst case is oh we're out of capacity
Caption: we're going to go find the server come
Caption: back in three months we might have
Caption: something for you right
Caption: it's really really different nowadays
Caption: and just on that Innovation certain
Caption: point because if people know me they
Caption: know I'd never shut up about the Dora
Caption: metrics and I've managed to find a way
Caption: to fit them in again
Caption: there so the reality is that nowadays we
Caption: actually have some statistically
Caption: verified ways of looking at entering
Caption: performance and it is not velocity
Caption: um the idea is you should be able to
Caption: deliver change frequently routinely you
Caption: don't break things very often and when
Caption: you do break things it's quick to fix
Caption: now a lot of the time people come back
Caption: and go well okay that's all right for
Caption: the digital natives the Googles whatever
Caption: blah blah
Caption: the reality is nowadays it's 26 of
Caption: businesses one in four from the survey
Caption: respondents so obviously there's going
Caption: to be a bias there but you can even see
Caption: over time 7 to 2026 this is not about
Caption: digital natives anymore this is about
Caption: table Stakes
Caption: if you can't do this
Caption: um you're really going to run into stuff
Caption: if you're not moving in this direction
Caption: you're really going to start to run into
Caption: problems a lot of sudden the business
Caption: can be like well our competitors
Caption: innovating so much faster than us it go
Caption: faster we've done safe now you can go
Caption: faster right and we've added more scrum
Caption: Masters we're going to go faster
Caption: not how it works at all
Caption: um so now on the monolith versus
Caption: microservice is about
Caption: the the way it used to be
Caption: um was used to have a simple arrangement
Caption: of complex objects you had virtual
Caption: machines that did a hell of a lot and
Caption: not that many of them
Caption: where it's kind of gone to now
Caption: especially in serverless applications is
Caption: it's a complex arrangement of simple
Caption: objects everything is easy to read is
Caption: about in isolation but instead the
Caption: complexity is actually moved it's made
Caption: from within the service to the
Caption: Integrations between services
Caption: so now when you're trying to test the
Caption: whole kit and caboodle on a monolith and
Caption: then you try and do the same in the
Caption: Lambda function you're not going to have
Caption: a good time because what you're trying
Caption: to do is get to the heart of the
Caption: complexity and the complexity is
Caption: actually moved where it is
Caption: the test pyramids everyone's familiar
Caption: surely
Caption: um
Caption: so this doesn't this really starts to
Caption: not apply
Caption: anymore
Caption: because really a lot of that complexity
Caption: that we used to kind of capture within
Caption: the unit testing start to move to
Caption: integration testing
Caption: Spotify came up with this I
Caption: it's better I mean all models um all
Caption: models are wrong some are useful it you
Caption: know it starts to actually point to the
Caption: fact that actually integration testing
Caption: unfortunately because there are caveats
Caption: on speed
Caption: um it's starting to get the more
Caption: important part to do
Caption: and really when you look at this there
Caption: are conversations we had about how
Caption: complex what are you actually trying to
Caption: achieve and this will speak to kind of
Caption: the years I've spent working on NATO's
Caption: platforms when you talk about this
Caption: complex we look at Lambda functions
Caption: there are kind of two general types I
Caption: see there is adoles Lambda is glue
Caption: because AWS haven't done something so
Caption: you write a Lambda function to do it for
Caption: them
Caption: um which is you know all the time and
Caption: really at this point you're probably
Caption: gonna have all integration tests and
Caption: very little implementation detail tests
Caption: because
Caption: your implementation detail really
Caption: doesn't mean anything anymore because if
Caption: you take that code out of AWS it's
Caption: useless
Caption: so what you know you don't have this
Caption: nice pure domain you're trying to look
Caption: after it's about like well actually all
Caption: I'm trying to do is Stitch to radio
Caption: Services together there is nothing
Caption: reusable here so really all I need to do
Caption: is integrate against AWS services not
Caption: really point trying to configure it so
Caption: you can test something locally because
Caption: what what is the point and I'll get into
Caption: more about how you can kind of test in
Caption: AWS a little bit more natively as we go
Caption: along
Caption: the kind of more interesting one
Caption: personally is with the main logic we're
Caption: actually trying to build like a system
Caption: of some form that Services uses not just
Caption: makes AWS go quicker
Caption: um and at this point you do end up with
Caption: a mix of integration implementation
Caption: detail
Caption: one of the core things to do when you're
Caption: doing serverless development is all the
Caption: side effects now if there's any
Caption: functional programmers in the room
Caption: they'll be very used to the comments
Caption: like talking about side effects as a
Caption: concept
Caption: you want to keep your domain logic like
Caption: the business logic of what you're trying
Caption: to do that should be kept pure if
Caption: there's anything if there's any Bodo
Caption: calls or AWS SDK calls anyway in your
Caption: business logic you've got a problem
Caption: the business logic shouldn't know it's
Caption: going into AWS or gcp or Azure or you
Caption: know a Raspberry Pi you've got sitting
Caption: on the desk you really shouldn't know
Caption: at the point you've made it so it
Caption: doesn't know
Caption: now I can test locally
Caption: because it's it's just logic that's
Caption: working it doesn't understand about any
Caption: external dependencies in any way so for
Caption: my domain logic I can actually iterate
Caption: on that very locally very very quickly
Caption: then I can independently test that the
Caption: drivers I've got that are interacting
Caption: with the cloud vendor
Caption: a work is expected and then some
Caption: end-to-end tests to stitch it together
Caption: this forces you to structure your code
Caption: in a particular way I didn't have enough
Caption: time to kind of go into a lot of depth
Caption: with it today but if you go look at
Caption: clean architecture there's a book
Caption: floating around there if you have a look
Caption: at the way they structure code
Caption: um that's generally how we do it
Caption: nowadays been doing for a few years it's
Caption: worked very well for this
Caption: um potentially how I go on time and I
Caption: know I'm stopping everyone from lunch I
Caption: might have chance to show an example but
Caption: we'll see how we go
Caption: um
Caption: one of these things is when you get to
Caption: this point
Caption: um you can this is a make file that I
Caption: use there's a Three Musketeers pattern
Caption: we use at container which I'm a big
Caption: proponent of
Caption: um effectively abstract all your repos
Caption: with make files to make it wonderful
Caption: um this is a internal project the make
Caption: file from an internal project and I
Caption: abstract it a little bit and taken some
Caption: stuff out but when you look at testing
Caption: and kind of setting up local development
Caption: there's no Docker nonsense in here
Caption: there's no setting up databases there's
Caption: no orchestrating a million dependencies
Caption: locally to do things and they have split
Caption: my tests up into integration and not
Caption: integration so I can very easily run my
Caption: local tests that'll run really fast and
Caption: check all my domain logic works and then
Caption: I can run integration tests and
Caption: separation and then for CI I've got to
Caption: test everything in report coverage right
Caption: because when you struck to the test like
Caption: that to get coverage you kind of need
Caption: both running and they've got set
Caption: end-to-end stuff that I did with bdd and
Caption: behave in in this example
Caption: but really I always
Caption: um shudder to think when I see what
Caption: level of complexity people take on to
Caption: try and get their testing apparatus set
Caption: up like okay now I've got to run Docker
Caption: I've got to run local stack I have to
Caption: kind of actually get on top of the AWS
Caption: SDK that I'm using to make sure it's
Caption: actually point to local stack apis
Caption: okay that you know all of a sudden it's
Caption: like well it worked on my machine yeah
Caption: who cares like that's so not a valuable
Caption: thing
Caption: um you want to be actually I want it to
Caption: work in AWS I want to be confident that
Caption: it works and really the amount of
Caption: competition get locally is pretty pretty
Caption: low when it comes down to it
Caption: this is a really interesting one I find
Caption: in serverless
Caption: um because I've done it and it's quite
Caption: quite a cool thing to do like the
Caption: testing heuristic like if if you kept
Caption: all your tests but deleted all the code
Caption: how confident are you that if you wrote
Caption: new code it would work would you feel
Caption: confident running that to production yes
Caption: or no I've gone through the point of
Caption: actually deleting functions because I
Caption: hated the way I read it initially and
Caption: rewrote it and pushed that to production
Caption: with sufficient testing like this is the
Caption: best heuristic I found in the case of
Caption: like okay well how do I know that my
Caption: tests are sufficient and it this is the
Caption: best thing like if you lose your code
Caption: today but you've got your testing there
Caption: you should be able to get close back to
Caption: production quality very very very
Caption: quickly
Caption: um yeah uh local stack I've already
Caption: mentioned it more times than I plan to
Caption: but now I'm going to mention it a whole
Caption: bunch more either so I can run locally I
Caption: am saved
Caption: um now I've done projects with local
Caption: stack I I've done done a lot with it to
Caption: be honest in the past
Caption: um
Caption: it's just not how to do things in the
Caption: cloud native sense yes you can emulate
Caption: address locally but why what what
Caption: actually leads us down the path of test
Caption: doubles because generally in the past it
Caption: was yeah at a testable at a mark
Caption: run some kind of slim down system that
Caption: kind of responds like the real thing
Caption: and they're fundamentally for when
Caption: orchestrating the dependency was too
Caption: expensive now what classifies the
Caption: expensive in here can be the amount of
Caption: time it takes to substantiate maybe as a
Caption: high running cost maybe you have to talk
Caption: with other teams to set them up like
Caption: obviously if you've got a sap install or
Caption: something like that you can't just run
Caption: up a new sap install the test against
Caption: that's not a realistic thing to do and
Caption: I'll talk about some strategies you can
Caption: use for that as you go on a little bit
Caption: but generally in serverless like yeah
Caption: you're trying to show that actually
Caption: managing independency is more expensive
Caption: than the test double therefore the test
Caption: double is worth having
Caption: but when you get to serverless
Caption: all those things that kind of drove the
Caption: dependency costs are no longer true
Caption: um hard to configure you've got
Caption: infrastructure as code you know running
Caption: up a Dynamo tables 20 seconds like it's
Caption: not that hard to actually configure
Caption: anymore High running costs most server
Caption: stuff is completely paper use if you're
Caption: using it for testing and just leave it
Caption: alone it will cost
Caption: cents a month right when you contrast to
Caption: compare this about how much a developer
Caption: costs a day and I normally use kind of a
Caption: benchmark of roughly a thousand dollars
Caption: a day
Caption: any time like if my developer has to
Caption: spend two minutes on this every day it's
Caption: more expensive than just running all the
Caption: stuff leaving all the stuff running and
Caption: generally in serverless if you're doing
Caption: it correctly with autonomous teams and
Caption: everything else you don't generally have
Caption: dependencies on other teams you have
Caption: empowered teams you're able to take
Caption: control of this for themselves and we
Caption: all know that handoffs are where
Caption: productivity goes to die
Caption: um so you know
Caption: generally if you find the empowered
Caption: teams thing really hard to do no
Caption: technology is going to save you you need
Caption: to revisit how you've actually
Caption: structured the organization
Caption: um just one of those things
Caption: so one of the common refrains and I even
Caption: get this internally and I've had this
Caption: debate so many times which one of the
Caption: reasons for writing this talk because I
Caption: got sick of writing the same thing in
Caption: slack every week people always like oh
Caption: but then I want to run a local test and
Caption: oh it takes a while to stand up the
Caption: infrastructure and I don't want to do
Caption: that every time I run my tests I said
Caption: who said that you're standing up the
Caption: infrastructure every single time you run
Caption: your test Suite that's that's insane why
Caption: would you do that
Caption: um this is just some python code that
Caption: I've used and I don't want to think how
Caption: many repos now
Caption: um that effectively just dump jumps in
Caption: and runs terraform terraform
Caption: um approve uh terraform apply and
Caption: terraform destroy what you'll notice is
Caption: there is a like environment variable
Caption: escape hatch
Caption: that if I set that environmental to
Caption: local I can just stand up the terraform
Caption: once outside of my test suite and it
Caption: will be long-lived it's not going to get
Caption: automatically torn down so I can lift
Caption: stuff up for the whole day and then pull
Caption: it down at the end of the day
Caption: so then when I'm actually running these
Caption: tests my data layer and all that kind of
Caption: stuff is long-lived so I'm not having to
Caption: wait every time for terraformal car
Caption: information or what have you to do
Caption: things instead for CI it defaults to
Caption: running new stuff up and see how you
Caption: want under 10 minutes like don't overly
Caption: stress about like my CI job took more
Caption: than two minutes now I'm losing
Caption: productivity it's not worth optimization
Caption: kind of Beyond 10 that seems to be the
Caption: general rule of thumb and generally with
Caption: terraform and cloud formation most stuff
Caption: you can rig up in two minutes and then
Caption: have all your tests run on top
Caption: um this was of an example that you know
Caption: something I did for a client back in the
Caption: UK with AWS config because some AWS
Caption: stuff like download you can build up
Caption: it's yours you can deal with it
Caption: something like AWS config and this is
Caption: again kind of working at the platform
Caption: level I was trying to build the Lambda
Caption: function the aggregated certain config
Caption: rules across the entire organization
Caption: reported kind of the classification of
Caption: resources
Caption: now AWS config
Caption: um will give me different responses
Caption: every single day because people change
Caption: things and I can't control that I can't
Caption: tell everyone no stop you can't deploy
Caption: resources because I need to test my
Caption: thing
Caption: so this kind of comes from the react
Caption: testing House of snapshot testing so
Caption: people have done um unfortunately had to
Caption: do front end work which I honestly hate
Caption: um then you will come across snapshot
Caption: testing in here within python there's a
Caption: library called Placebo that allows you
Caption: to effectively you call AWS once and it
Caption: stores the response so next time you're
Caption: on your test it replays that response
Caption: back to you
Caption: this is higher Fidelity than local stack
Caption: because it's actually coming from AWS
Caption: and it allows you to actually test
Caption: things properly so I can you know verify
Caption: that my function running actually does
Caption: um
Caption: it does give me the right responses and
Caption: like has anyone ever configured local
Caption: stack with the python helper because
Caption: it's about five times more code than
Caption: that just to make it work
Caption: this is really really simple they get
Caption: get committed to get everyone's working
Caption: from the same thing really really simple
Caption: to do if you can't um control if you
Caption: can't orchestrate the dependency
Caption: properly then you can just capture the
Caption: responses you can refresh it
Caption: occasionally but don't change your code
Caption: and try and do the refresh at the same
Caption: time it's one or the other
Caption: um
Caption: there are better things there are more
Caption: Cloud native things there are things far
Caption: more in line with what we want to do AWS
Caption: themselves have released some accelerate
Caption: serverless framework has a similar thing
Caption: where instead as you make code changes
Caption: they are live streamed in data s you get
Caption: full Fidelity testing at speed and you
Caption: get true Cloud native testing when you
Caption: kind of get down to it and as you
Caption: actually properly secure your Cloud
Caption: environments and you actually have
Caption: production like infrastructure
Caption: running as you in the account will not
Caption: allow you to test anymore
Caption: because data should be locked away KMS
Caption: Keys you should not have access I'll
Caption: I'll make the point that generally most
Caption: environments are not set up to this
Caption: level but they should be
Caption: but fundamentally you want to be
Caption: actually assuming the principle of the
Caption: Lambda function or equivalent when
Caption: you're actually doing this testing
Caption: because it actually tells you what's
Caption: actually going to happen
Caption: um you know you'd actually if you try
Caption: and do all this local SEC testing or
Caption: even just testing locally against AWS
Caption: apis or GPS apis or what have you
Caption: if your security matures to a certain
Caption: point it's all going to break
Caption: um and it should break because the
Caption: reality is you should be testing against
Caption: production like infrastructure
Caption: production like infrastructure shouldn't
Caption: be allowing you to get into all the
Caption: databases and pull stuff out as
Caption: willy-nilly to check things have gone
Caption: where they should go right
Caption: um
Caption: so coming back to this refinement piece
Caption: I talked about before
Caption: when you're testing this local stack you
Caption: are testing how your system works in
Caption: local stack and you're bringing your
Caption: mental model closer and closer in tune
Caption: with that not actually with where it's
Caption: actually going to be running in
Caption: production
Caption: um for example in local stack face fixed
Caption: this ages ago but when I was using it I
Caption: found that the dynamodb types were a lot
Caption: looser so what was working in local
Caption: stack when I went to AWS was being
Caption: rejected by the API now you know
Caption: that in and of itself maybe lost me 10
Caption: minutes of time but 10 minutes of time
Caption: multiplied by the amount of devs hitting
Caption: all these random little edge cases and
Caption: all those kind of things
Caption: doesn't really work and also when you
Caption: start to look at local stack yeah kind
Caption: of the basics are there and
Caption: um you've got like the services enough
Caption: to wet like wet your whistle you can get
Caption: in like okay lambda's there Dino's there
Caption: cool I can start working now I want to
Caption: kind of I have x-ray in there and I have
Caption: a whole bunch of other things in here
Caption: looks like cool payers no what this was
Caption: all about saving costs against AWS what
Caption: are you telling me I now have to pay a
Caption: license for every single developer are
Caption: you insane and fundamentally these ideas
Caption: costs are so minuscule like your local
Caption: set cost is going to massively outweigh
Caption: your Cloud Bill and this is insane
Caption: um
Caption: it's kind of on the last
Caption: the last kind of rant I'm going to go on
Caption: um again this is comes from people and
Caption: it's not that these approaches were were
Caption: wrong at the time they were came from a
Caption: certain time certain place certain
Caption: Paradigm and certain ways of working and
Caption: they made a lot of sense
Caption: um the point is that when you go to
Caption: serverless that a lot of you need to
Caption: reevaluate how you do things one of
Caption: these things is I mean I've
Caption: hardly ever used a debugger I'm really
Caption: bad with them but you know a lot of the
Caption: time people get used to being able to
Caption: attach a debugger to their running code
Caption: so they've got the variables as they're
Caption: going and all that kind of stuff
Caption: and then they get to this point like how
Caption: do I attach my debugger to the Lambda
Caption: functions you can't you know people used
Caption: to do what seems in retrospect insane
Caption: where they'd like go onto a production
Caption: system attach a debugger to a running
Caption: Java process to have a look at what's
Caption: going on
Caption: um you know in my mind that's insane but
Caption: I can also understand why they did it at
Caption: the time but nowadays you know that's
Caption: not an option and you shouldn't be
Caption: annoyed that's not an option but some
Caption: people do get annoyed
Caption: um you know this this is just absolute
Caption: classic meme within the space right
Caption: um the thing is it used to be loaded at
Caption: as being ridiculous when in reality it's
Caption: actually the case of how you should be
Caption: doing things for a large part you know
Caption: we always come out with the adage that
Caption: you know code is read 10 more times and
Caption: it's written the reality is it's run in
Caption: production of thousands to millions of
Caption: times for every time it's written for
Caption: any code that's doing a lot of stuff
Caption: so really where you need to focus your
Caption: efforts is in how do I understand when
Caption: stuff breaks in production more so than
Caption: how do I fix stuff locally
Caption: one of the things that I do a lot with
Caption: teams
Caption: um is beginning with the end in mind and
Caption: this is trying to bring SRE principles
Caption: in just just kind of service lab
Caption: objectives not the other six
Caption: um but just looking at how can I use
Caption: Services objectives to Define what I'm
Caption: doing
Caption: um you kind of got whenever you're kind
Caption: of developing anything really and these
Caption: are two questions that every single
Caption: feature should be asked is how will I
Caption: know my feature is broken and that gives
Caption: you your like mean time to
Caption: identification and how will I determine
Caption: why it's broken which is my your mean
Caption: time to recovery if
Caption: on every like pull request review if
Caption: you're not asking these questions you're
Caption: going to end up pushing code which isn't
Caption: operationally sound maybe functionally
Caption: correct but when it blows up you're
Caption: going to be really sorry at the end
Caption: right
Caption: um
Caption: for me you should be looking at this one
Caption: first
Caption: before you actually develop the feature
Caption: you should be building the apparatus
Caption: that allows you to understand your
Caption: feature is broken
Caption: and then second you can just type in why
Caption: it's broken
Caption: so SLI is slos slas I talk about these
Caption: way too much but for anyone that's not
Caption: not familiar
Caption: um service level SLI serviceable
Caption: indicators defines your success and
Caption: failure so for the feature how can I
Caption: measure that it was successful or it
Caption: failed in production what's actually
Caption: look like
Caption: service level objective then defines
Caption: what an acceptable failure frequency is
Caption: so you know for every thousand requests
Caption: one's allowed to fail something like
Caption: that expressed as percentages I'm sure
Caption: you've kind of all seen slas floating
Caption: around and then an SLA is a like
Caption: contractual obligation defies a penalty
Caption: for every time you actually fall
Caption: underneath that failure goal
Caption: um reality most systems you can just
Caption: stop at slos especially for internal
Caption: systems
Caption: um one one thing I'm going to get into
Caption: here uh which is just something that
Caption: always shits me is an SLO written in
Caption: Confluence doesn't mean anything at all
Caption: um I call them schroding as slos because
Caption: no one knows whether it's alive or dead
Caption: um I hate the I hate how often I see
Caption: systems where people don't know whether
Caption: system is alive or dead they're just
Caption: kind of hoping it is
Caption: um you know
Caption: not going to say anything about putting
Caption: them in a box with poison and waiting
Caption: for a timer um one thing that we've done
Caption: and this is going open source this is
Caption: not a sales pitch please don't take it
Caption: as one whereas we built at container I
Caption: built this for a client in the UK a um a
Caption: way of dashboarding things in AWS that
Caption: was SLO focused that we kept kind of
Caption: it's all serverless all very extensible
Caption: um but this you know when we on the team
Caption: I built this with
Caption: the first thing we did for every new
Caption: feature was added to the SLO dashboard
Caption: before we started working on the feature
Caption: you can see some at the bottom around
Caption: patching compliance testing and backups
Caption: and stuff like that I built the backups
Caption: was one I did just before I left where
Caption: we were running out a new backup
Caption: solution so the first thing I did was
Caption: roll out and this was where the config
Caption: bit came in as well the ability to
Caption: understand how many instances are
Caption: currently outside of backup plans how
Caption: many don't have active backups with the
Caption: idea that as I build the backup solution
Caption: and roll it out and this is on a this is
Caption: across 500 AWS accounts you can
Caption: understand why I'm trying to track these
Caption: numbers because you can't possibly hold
Caption: that in your head but I wanted to be
Caption: able to show as we roll it out that
Caption: these numbers going down
Caption: because otherwise you're a backup
Caption: solution and this is a classic thing we
Caption: built the tool is anyone using the tool
Caption: I don't know
Caption: okay why do you build it
Caption: and really fundamentally when you're
Caption: doing this Cloud native development and
Caption: talking about testing and getting into
Caption: debugging you should be trying to debug
Caption: your development with the same tools
Caption: you're going to use to debug in
Caption: production
Caption: because otherwise and this is another
Caption: rant of mine debug logs why do they
Caption: exist why do they ever get committed to
Caption: Mainline because you get them in
Caption: production you're like I'll be able to
Caption: figure this out if I had the debug logs
Caption: great what are you going to do about it
Caption: now if you if you wrote These logs to
Caption: understand things in development you
Caption: should be turning them on in production
Caption: as well I I yeah it's just a round of
Caption: pie because again going back in time you
Caption: used to be able to switch on debug logs
Caption: by changing the environment variable or
Caption: something like that you can't really do
Caption: that anymore and even if you can like
Caption: transient issues that you see that have
Caption: disappeared you really wish you had that
Caption: log data oh it's gone oh well too bad
Caption: right
Caption: um really you get down to what you end
Caption: up with you know be able to use X-ray
Caption: and cloudwatch
Caption: um you know grafana Prometheus all these
Caption: kind of tools in production and you know
Caption: Cloud operations suite and Azure logic
Caption: monitor you know yeah you apply the
Caption: tools synonyms for whatever Cloud you
Caption: use
Caption: um but really if you can't use these to
Caption: figure out why your development's not
Caption: working how are you going to use them to
Caption: figure out a production is not working
Caption: um you know debugger and local tools and
Caption: that kind of stuff you're not going to
Caption: have them when you really need them
Caption: so why are you focused on becoming
Caption: really strong with them
Caption: like when you look at honeycomb and
Caption: observability which I suggest everyone
Caption: do you know they instrument everything
Caption: and they use honeycomb for all their all
Caption: their kind of needs it allows you to
Caption: actually just yeah
Caption: your code's going to be running in
Caption: production for much longer than it takes
Caption: you to write it
Caption: you should be focusing on that
Caption: and when you get good with the
Caption: production tools they're not going to
Caption: slow down your development Cycles by
Caption: using these things but it makes a lot
Caption: more sense than trying to use a debugger
Caption: locally and then getting stuck in
Caption: production
Caption: so I'm actually running ahead of time
Caption: which is nice unusual for me and I know
Caption: I'm keeping everyone from lunch so you
Caption: know go figure
Caption: um but I just wanted to kind of revisit
Caption: back revisit back on the three key
Caption: lessons the one testing period is
Caption: anti-pattern there's the testing
Caption: honeycomb that
Caption: um Spotify have
Caption: it's better I still think as an industry
Caption: we can do better than that
Caption: um emulator the rest of your
Caption: disappointment I hope any of you that
Caption: are using local stack or equivalents
Caption: today
Caption: um maybe maybe I might get lucky and
Caption: some of you might revisit that decision
Caption: next week I understand that it's
Caption: investment and everything else and oh
Caption: we're going to change the way we test
Caption: makes a product owner cry
Caption: um because they're not getting any
Caption: features but you know you need that time
Caption: to actually invest in you know paying
Caption: down Tech debt and to be honest if
Caption: you're using local stack I would
Caption: classify that as technical debt nowadays
Caption: um unless it's testing as a shopping
Caption: code hits production you really like
Caption: that's what you should be focusing for
Caption: because that's where your code delivers
Caption: value and where braking actually becomes
Caption: a problem so yeah fundamentally look at
Caption: what tools are in the cloud that you can
Caption: use to understand your production code
Caption: use those for your development code at
Caption: the same time
Caption: that that was all I had so hopefully
Caption: there's some questions
Caption: first of all Josh I love your brutally
Caption: honest approach
Caption: um it is fantastic it's very real I just
Caption: wanted to throw that out there question
Caption: oh sorry
Caption: sorry yeah so um I guess if you need to
Caption: keep CI tests fast
Caption: um that requires that you're able to
Caption: kind of spin up an ephemeral stack and
Caption: then tear it down in a matter of minutes
Caption: like what patterns
Caption: um would you use when you have like a
Caption: hybrid architecture where you kind of
Caption: necessarily have one or two server full
Caption: resources say AWS elasticsearch for
Caption: example
Caption: yeah at that point you've got to make
Caption: like a trade-off at some point for going
Caption: well the cost of keeping it running
Caption: versus the time saving you should be
Caption: able to kind of when I come back to that
Caption: kind of thousand dollars a day you can
Caption: run the data and go it's going to be
Caption: more effective to do it one way or the
Caption: other but I think it would be try and
Caption: get the data together to go running
Caption: elasticsearch is going to cost us this
Caption: much if we just leave it on
Caption: okay well is that worth the speed up and
Caption: development time for that like it comes
Caption: down to you've got you've got to make
Caption: trade-offs you just want to make the
Caption: cheapest trade-off whatever that is
Caption: um but yeah elasticsearch is a pain and
Caption: it's expensive as well so it's a hard
Caption: one and in that case you might want to
Caption: actually eat the CI run or yeah
Caption: generally have some kind of mocked
Caption: version of elasticsearch I'm not saying
Caption: you can't Mark I'm just saying don't
Caption: default to it if it's going to be
Caption: cheaper and you're going to get the
Caption: Fidelity you want then Mark away but
Caption: just it should be not the default
Caption: position it should be yeah the other
Caption: ones are too expensive we need to go
Caption: down this path
Caption: fantastic next one
Caption: alrighty heckler's in the front audience
Caption: now I am told you are here to Hackle so
Caption: have we got any heckling
Caption: no right all right so disappointing
Caption: looks like uh I'm gonna get all the
Caption: books so uh joking seriously if we've
Caption: got any questions guys please put your
Caption: hand up
Caption: fantastic thank you
Caption: what's your opinion on uh sort of Docker
Caption: versus Lambda so you know running native
Caption: Native lambdas versus running
Caption: Docker containers or Docker serverless
Caption: or
Caption: um I mean with container
Caption: it's an abstraction but uh it's also
Caption: another level of testability yeah I like
Caption: Dockers for I like Docker using Docker
Caption: images Docker containers for local
Caption: development to try and get some
Caption: standardization on environments but if
Caption: you're throwing them into production
Caption: be aware that you're accepting a high
Caption: level of accountability when it comes to
Caption: your security posture in terms of
Caption: managing the containers fixing
Caption: vulnerabilities all that kind of stuff
Caption: like you know when you're in a lab when
Caption: you're running Lambda without containers
Caption: you know AWS fixed stuff
Caption: for you underneath if you've got a
Caption: container strategy and everything else
Caption: and you've got all that kind of stuff
Caption: in-house because maybe you've got some
Caption: kubernetes somewhere else and whatever
Caption: and you can kind of piggyback on that
Caption: but I still generally try and go with
Caption: Native Lambda where possible because
Caption: it's less work
Caption: for me to do from a security perspective
Caption: operationally it's not fantastically
Caption: different but still doggier pulling
Caption: extra packages that you have to rotate
Caption: and fix the CVS for
Caption: um I think Sheldon had one
Caption: listen
Caption: one repo one function Primal and a mono
Caption: repo mono repo
Caption: what one
Caption: [Laughter]
Caption: one one Function One repo which my God
Caption: you'd hit you GitHub limits in about a
Caption: week
Caption: um but uh
Caption: like
Caption: I always think start with monorepo
Caption: because it's easier and you can wait
Caption: till you hit a scaling Point you're like
Caption: actually multi-repo work for us like
Caption: normally when I started a multi repo
Caption: before and it's like okay well now we
Caption: need to share this kind of package of
Caption: types around between the repos now I've
Caption: got to figure all that out and it's like
Caption: um now I've got to push dependency yeah
Caption: we've got pulled dependency version
Caption: Independence he's like oh what's the
Caption: value in doing this oh we have multiple
Caption: repos yeah but what's the value multiple
Caption: repos like if you're working in vertical
Caption: slice and you have your code set up
Caption: properly that you shouldn't be hitting
Caption: like merge conflicts all the time or
Caption: anything like that and at least it keeps
Caption: your code more consistent more easily
Caption: um I've kind of gone back and forth on
Caption: this over the years but at the moment I
Caption: just go monore until I feel the pain
Caption: especially if you do clean architecture
Caption: like you end up with one code base that
Caption: you kind of change the entry points for
Caption: to do different Lambda functions so you
Caption: end up with just kind of one blob of
Caption: code that you deploy in different kind
Caption: of configurations to do things
Caption: um which is generally a lot easier from
Caption: a packaging point of view it makes stuff
Caption: a lot simpler
Caption: well done because I didn't know what you
Caption: were going to answer to my why because I
Caption: am not sure what I'm on read probably as
Caption: if I'm honest guys so sorry for throwing
Caption: you a little bit for success
Caption: [Music]
Caption: [Laughter]
Caption: have you applied these techniques in a
Caption: kubernetes environment
Caption: yeah I mean it's
Caption: not fundamentally all that different it
Caption: depends on how much managed Services
Caption: you're running and all that kind of
Caption: stuff but effectively I think the
Caption: patterns still apply like when I um did
Caption: some work for one of the mining
Caption: companies in town a few years ago and we
Caption: built it and we deployed it into Lambda
Caption: and ECS from the same code base we just
Caption: had to change stuff on the edge and it
Caption: was the same approach for both
Caption: um there's nothing like effectively your
Caption: code to a large degree really shouldn't
Caption: understand where the hell it's being
Caption: deployed
Caption: um and you should be trying to take
Caption: those changes and push them right out to
Caption: the far edge of your code again clean
Caption: architecture helps a lot with this but
Caption: yeah running in kubernetes or not the
Caption: same principles I think still apply of
Caption: just try and use the cloud as much as
Caption: possible and stop trying to run like a
Caption: postgres database locally or whatever
Caption: um like you shouldn't need to I mean
Caption: postgres is a little bit different
Caption: because it's such a standard like stable
Caption: platform that the emulation is generally
Caption: very very high fidelity but still like
Caption: you know try and figure out what you can
Caption: do cheapest and generally developer time
Caption: is the is the big one for cheap families
Caption: don't I know sometimes you guys have
Caption: different ideas on that but most of us
Caption: it's developer time you guys have scale
Caption: problems that all of us wish we had so
Caption: it changes the needle sometimes
Caption: alrighty we can probably fit one more
Caption: question in if we have it
Caption: thanks guys
Caption: um do you kind of have any thoughts on
Caption: what might be good kinds of production
Caption: tests to do and maybe sort of
Caption: organizational pushback on doing that
Caption: kind of thing
Caption: I mean yeah organizations really always
Caption: push back on testing I think is that um
Caption: I really like the service lab objective
Caption: stuff I really like being able to
Caption: understand
Caption: Um how my feature is supposed to be
Caption: working I'm going to track how that
Caption: feature is working
Caption: um and having just that really quick
Caption: feedback I can see I'm burning error
Caption: budget so something's gone wrong I do
Caption: think the SRE looking at SRE for how to
Caption: run stuff in production is probably the
Caption: way to go but I would say that's SRE as
Caption: in like the Google Books not what a lot
Caption: of vendors sell
Caption: um today because I've had so many
Caption: arguments on redefining it at
Caption: Enterprises where gsis got him first and
Caption: they're like oh and then there's a
Caption: rebadged ITIL build and run that's not
Caption: where Siri is
Caption: um I think in production is pretty much
Caption: like how do I know something's broken is
Caption: is the big thing and service level
Caption: objectives are probably the kind of the
Caption: becoming dominant way of doing that like
Caption: there is the classic monitoring of my
Caption: CPU is spiking send an alert and it's
Caption: like no that's you need the kind of
Caption: business impact level metrics to
Caption: understand that customers are being
Caption: impacted because you measure from the
Caption: customer then CPU spiking useful
Caption: diagnostic metric when you're in kind of
Caption: debug mode but you shouldn't be alerting
Caption: and actually be alerting on you know
Caption: winning so many 500 like 500 responses
Caption: are spiking something's gone wrong on
Caption: our API cool let's go and fix that
Caption: um again observability in honeycomb is
Caption: the big kind of I think it's the big
Caption: paradigm shift that's coming
Caption: um where you've got like high
Caption: cardinality events okay I definitely do
Caption: not have time to get into that in any
Caption: great detail but I can afterwards if
Caption: you'd like I'm more than happy to
Caption: 100 look guys that's probably time Josh
Caption: but a big round of applause
Caption: um that was Unreal
Caption: now just a few friendly reminders lunch
Caption: will be immediately served once you
Caption: leave this store now you can go to the
Caption: North or the South we 've stuck over in
Caption: front of the theater room there's going
Caption: to be food sort of everywhere basically
Caption: from what I'm reading here
Caption: uh lunchtime sessions will commence at 2
Caption: 30
Caption: 5 in the theater that's definitely a
Caption: typo at 1 35 in the theater and both the
Caption: river rooms notes do not do what I did
Caption: before and eat your Apple because you
Caption: will get in trouble in there
Caption: um attendees there will also be breakout
Caption: sessions that will commence again
Caption: at
Caption: 2 15.
Caption: definitely 215 and I've got one in here
Caption: with a wonderful wonderful lady and she
Caption: will be talking about standing on this
Caption: blah blah blah
Caption: standing on the shoulder of giants the
Caption: next great generation in Tech nichu so
Caption: on that note thank you again Josh thank
Caption: you heckles and everybody have a great
Caption: lunch